a lot of young people go onto social
media and they see all these you know
beautiful pictures of people you're only
showing your best side on social media
you're getting the filtered shot looking
your best hair and makeup for these
young girls who get all dolled up and
take all these pictures and so if you're
not looking like that 24/7 it could
probably be very depressing for someone
who goes on and feels like why can't I
live up to that standard how come I'm
not setting the bar that high and being
on social media on the other hand it's a
lot of work I think the business side is
a very important part of social media
because like it or leave it
it's a way that this generation is you
know Zee gen is conducting business it's
just like Kylie for example has a
complete makeup business that she's
created over the last three years and
it's sold right now at this time in June
of 2018 it's just on econ right so the
way she promotes her brand is through
social media channels and all of her
different platforms and she's got
hundreds of millions of followers who
are waiting for her to drop a new
product
[Music]